[Music]
hi there Steve Kaufman here again and
today as I have been doing I'm gonna
follow up my Spanish video with a video
where I talk about learning Spanish so I
mean as I've said so many times the big
thing in language learning is motivation
you know and I keep on repeating it
because you know it's not about talent
it's not about classes or teachers or
methods
it's a primarily about motivation the
amount of time you spend on the task and
noticing noticing what's going on in the
language and I think that's where the
the good language learners have become
better at noticing at becoming they've
become more aware more alert what
happens in the language so Spanish
unexpanded
is one of the most attractive languages
to learn and I'll explain why I mean we
can all be motivated to learn a specific
language like Mongolian or Finnish or I
don't know you know Georgian because we
have a friend or we have a particular
interest or we have some other specific
thing that's very specific to our own
interests already Korean for Korean
drama or Japanese for anime so all of
these things are or for business and to
all kinds of reasons but Spanish has a
number of real big advantages in terms
of a language to learn first of all a
lot of people speak Spanish you've got
all of Latin America except Brazil
basically Heidi and Spain and they're
all these countries are quite different
and even in terms of regional
differences so there's a lot of kind of
culture there when I think of Spain
which I know much better than Latin
America to me Spain or Spanish is about
color it's about music you know it's a
place where people have fun you know
I'll still remember sitting in in
Marbella in southern Spain in the
the street they had closed down the
street and the restaurant had their
tables out there it's 11 o'clock at
night we're sitting down under the skies
the star you know lets sky we can smell
the Jasmine around us we're having
dinner at 11 o'clock at night you don't
do that at home it's like time yeah it
stands still and we're eating this
wonderful meal and nothing matters and I
think the Spanish have an ability to
live in the moment and enjoy the moment
and so those are the kinds of things you
enjoy there and color I can still
remember being there in the 60s going to
a bullfight now granted there are animal
lovers we don't think that's a great
thing to do with this the music and the
colors and the Sun powerful Sun or
hitchhiking into into Valencia and
seeing the the orange of the or the the
green and orange of the orange fields or
then this was in the spring and then
going on to Cordoba and civilians
smelling might have been two different
trips it's like 40 odd years ago
smelling the blossoms and stuff like
that I mean those are the kinds of
powerful colors and and and the music of
course not only flamenco but all of the
music and so you know Spain is powerful
that way and recently I visited Mexico
and with my wife we were in some again
de yen de guanajuato and Mexico City and
again powerful colors friendly people
music so and and I was briefly in Chile
but I don't remember very much
that's like 1980 but I am sure that Peru
is different in Argentina is different
than Central America is different and
even you know other cultures like the
Mayan or the Aztec cultures not come to
us through Spanish so there's a whole
world there okay so that makes Spanish
attractive I think should motivate
people to want to learn it there also
those are all very popular tourist
destinations so and
Spanish is is a I think is an easy
language to learn and it's kind of like
the door to the whole former Latin in
other words Romance language world if
you learn Spanish you can learn
Portuguese 200 million people in Brazil
you can learn Italian which is a
phenomenal language and has so much
history behind it and the Spanish kind
of leads you into this world French has
its difficulties pronunciation wise
whatever but the vocabulary is there so
I think there's tremendous motivation
there should be for a lot of people to
learn Spanish not just because if you're
an American there's more and more
Hispanic people and you might want they
want a mini Spanish to find a job or
something I think these are minor issues
I think to me and I should add that it's
been shown that because language
learning is a long road someone said on
one of my youtube videos that you know
that shirt that initial period where you
don't know the language and outside you
can speak the language that you can go
at that based on what they call
extrinsic motivation like I want a
better job but once you realize that
it's actually a very long haul to get to
genuine fluency that's where you need
that intrinsic motivation like you like
the language you like people there has
to be that personal you know desire
commitment to the language and I think
Spain Spanish is an easy language to get
committed to so I've talked a lot about
that sort of commitment they now lets it
move on to the language Spanish is an
easy language to learn for a number of
reasons first of all like all Romance
languages for English speakers there is
a lot of common vocabulary lots Spanish
has the advantage that the spelling is
extremely consistent unlike French for
example the vowels are pure ah you know
there's no diphthongs diphthongs the use
of accents I always find accents a
little bit annoying because I have to
change my keypad in order to accommodate
them but the system is quite consistent
as to when we use accent and spat in
Spanish
and when we don't look at their role
you'll forget it the first few times but
eventually it'll stick you know
masculine and feminine most words almost
all words that end in O or masculine
almost all words ending in a are
feminine with a few exceptions so to
that extent it's easier to tell the
gender of verbs and nouns what else is
there I mean verbs like all Romance
languages you gotta come to terms with
it there is a very good website called
verax ve RBI x.com and there you can
find conjugation tables for I don't know
how many languages including Spanish
refer to it from time to time difficult
to kind of I find to try to concentrate
on memorizing those tables you just have
to look at it from time to time and
start noticing as you're doing your
listening and reading what else is it I
mean there's this scent and it's started
to have two words for is like something
that you are permanently is so something
that you are like happy is a start a
difficult concept at first you'll
continue to make mistakes in it it
doesn't prevent you from understanding
it doesn't prevent people from
understanding you it's something that
you kind of work away at it's like there
are also the Spanish for for like por
and para again it's something you read
the explanation you want to understand
it and slowly it sort of sinks in they
have funny little things like they put
their exclamation exclamation marks and
question marks and upside down at the
front of the sentence and another one at
the back it's the only language that I'm
aware of that does that I don't know why
they do it everybody else manages fine
without that you know when there's a
question or you know whatever
explanation
I'm sure Spanish people who read other
languages don't miss them but at any
rate that's a little idiosyncrasy of the
Spanish language things are fairly
consistent so it's a very rewarding
language in that regard because you can
actually move fairly quickly in the
language Oh what else
the
people have trouble with the in terms of
pronunciation with the rolled R and I
think it's just one of those things it's
like the in French you just gotta work
at it and work at it until you get it I
found for example you know they begin
the the first artist in Spain is it's a
double are draught and I find it's
useful to almost act as if you're gonna
say N or D so you get your tongue right
up to the top of your mouth and then you
say rota rota whatever Ricardo Ricardo
strong art and of course
Pedro if it's a double art you gotta get
two of them but that might be a bit of a
difficulty the other thing is the is the
vowels if you're an English speaker try
to hear how those vows are spoken it's
ah you know gato it's not gato gato its
e
it's you know in theory or whatever the
vowels
I think it's worth making an effort to
get those down what else is there I
don't remember I was gonna make some
notes well there are some for example
when you like something it's megusta so
there are some expressions that are
sometimes reflexive oh yes and the
subjunctive again like all Romance
languages subjunctive is there gradually
you'll get more and more of them right
I'm not gonna explain why why we use the
subjunctive it's you know it's that
sense of uncertainty or wanting or
something that we aren't sure is gonna
happen we use the subjunctive you just
have to get used to but Spanish is a
wonderful journey I I think people who
if you're not sure what language to
study study Spanish and I've been asked
to keep my videos shorter so I'm already
over 10 minutes I'm gonna shut down
right here thank you for this thing and
I hope this encourages you to learn
Spanish bye for now